who is the shrouded sadistic sordid
field who mains and Ritter's why this
bloodthirsty orgy
this Holocaust of lives
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well ciao everybody
well yeah I wanted to say that because
of the topic today I thought that would
be relevant topic is jello fine shallow
films yes it is yes I don't know much
about jello films I know we're gonna
have to you gonna tell me about him well
that's good cuz I know a lot about him
and I've been actually been wanting to
do this topic for a really long time cuz
it's one of my very favorite genres yeah
we're on subgenres we're on a horror
network so we can do this yeah and I'm
yeah and I kind of actually in the
future I kind of want to mix in more
more horror stuff no more horror fiction
and we have writers and stuff that are
in the network yeah so you know maybe
some crossover yeah I mean we did do we
did do that show that was a that was
about the shining and stuff like that
was like our first episode right so I
kind of want to throw in a few more of
those yeah and i you know i've i've seen
a few giallo films I you know I was a
kid you know I used to run into him a
lot yes he liked the like that covers
the posters there yeah it was
illustrated into girls and [ __ ] yeah my
mom would let me watch that was good
so probably a wise move yeah because a
lot of immersive I'm you know because
they were European a lot of them were
super gory and super [ __ ]
yeah and they hate they kind of have an
underground yeah yeah they were I mean
they were pretty much like they're
they're kind of like classier
exploitation cinema like over here you
get like the grungy kind of exploitation
flicks and stuff like that they were
like that but you know they could get
away with a lot more later on I stumbled
into a few of them you know the cannibal
ones and stuff like that well those
aren't jell-o well it was no I wasn't
really a fan yeah
well I did like that I do like Lucci a
bulge a zombie movies that cuz they were
super disgusting
well the first thing is I need to make
the announcement that you guys the
unseen hand a new exploration of
poltergeist phenomena that is my new
book yeah and it is now out in all
formats including audio go print ebook
audiobook all formats are now available
on Amazon for sale right and if you're
into poltergeist kind of stuff which you
know I'm sure some of you are cuz we've
done pulled
guy shows on here you guys don't listen
to him then you will probably love this
book it has a hundred and possesses like
120 cases I think I ended up writing
about like 120 poltergeist cases all the
way back to the first century you know
most of them most of them from the last
couple centuries obviously because
that's where most of the yeah took her a
long time to research this book - yeah
uh it's got a lot of good what do you
call it testimony of witnesses
yeah and that's it's not just kind of
[ __ ] cases it's ones that were
documented by law enforcement of the
time and yeah I mean I try to stick with
ones you know like ones that were super
popular even if they weren't yeah so
once again did some of them I had to put
in there just because they were so
famous right a couple of the famous ones
you you basically have to include or
kind of questionable whether or not they
were actually poltergeist whether it was
a hoax but that you actually kind of
yeah point out that you know this case
really you know such a such case here
this one may not really yeah some people
said it was a hoax this is why they said
that blog blog so I kind of tried to
keep it you know neutral but yes bounced
yeah but where people thought it was a
hoax you know I I would say that right
that's the way to put it yeah and I'll
say the audio book is long it's yeah
it's a bit slow its eleven and a half
seven and a half hours long it's about
it I think it's a foreigner at some page
book yeah right yeah yeah I think it's
400 pages on the dot actually okay the
print versions the brothers yeah so if
you want that and you can go get it and
write me a review if you would get
really awesome well that's gonna happen
automatically yeah and also oh and as
usual we want to give a shout out to
project Entertainment Network and Arman
Rossum Elia yeah who runs it horror
writer awesome guy yeah welcome welcome
to the podcast our new podcaster so I
mean damn our traffic is like tripled
every week or every month in it yeah I
think actually our download numbers from
just the audio version on Youtube
version of the show but the audio
version of the show actually more than
tripled for a month right like from from
February to March the numbers were yeah
more than three times it's almost
probably close to 2,000 downloads a
month now right no more it's a thousand
downloads a week winner yeah something
like that
right which that's so Brad right and
grow hey yay so you know a few guys on
the podcast if you have me the contact
us you want to ask us any questions you
can subscribe to our YouTube channel and
ask questions right there on the comment
section of the video or you can contact
us on Facebook yeah on the Facebook page
13 o'clock podcasts we have it yeah we
have a page or you can contact me
Jenny Ashford either on my author page
or on my regular personal page and you
know if you want to suggest topics stuff
like that you know which we've done some
suggestions so far it's like we only do
one show a week so it's we'll try to
eventually get to all of them and if you
have a podcast of your own you want
Jenny on as a guest to show her new
cloak or anything just contacts yeah
that's fine that would be our we've
already got a bunch of stuff lined up
but we could always take more yeah yeah
especially if you like paranormal tech
podcast if you have one like that and
you want me because I've been on a bunch
of them and if she goes on as a guest
we'll announce that in the podcast
probably before I throw it in the stream
yeah cuz she's going back on tour so you
know so yeah they may want to hear you
our other shows yeah that would be good
alright so that's pretty much all the
housekeeping out of the way first right
yeah now let's start talking about GL
films yeah yeah I'm so I can't tell you
how excited I am about this topic what
is GL o mean well it's actually it's
just the Italian word for yellow yellow
why is it yellow okay the reason that
the that they're called that is because
in 1929 there was a publisher in Italy
called mondadori and they started
publishing Italian translations of like
American and British mystery crime
thrillers you know Agatha Christie
Raymond Chandler that type of thing
Edgar Wallace he's a British crime
writer and they all had these bright
yellow covers and there's pictures on
one line but they're really cool-looking
covers with like the cool artwork and
everything like that was women in
distress and all that and these books
were so popular and they they turned out
so many of them that the very color
yellow became associated with that type
of thing but
then other publishers started jumping
into the mix and they started doing
their own ripoff copies of translations
and they would do yellow covers too so
the e so the color became associated
with that genre and at first it was a
literary genre you know pretty much and
like I said very influenced by American
and British crime you knew our type of
stuff okay
you know damsels in distress and
hard-boiled detectives and all that kind
of stuff so something like a full like
Italian Pulp Fiction yes right and but
then there were also kind of kind of
gothic elements to it too because really
the movie genre and I think most people
now okay here's an interesting thing now
in Italy when you call a movie or a book
a giallo
that's pretty much any thriller right so
any movie that we would consider a
thriller it gives you a basic instinct
Silence of the Lambs okay anything like
that they would consider that a jello
okay but in english-speaking countries
Java has a very specific genre yeah it's
an Italian movie yeah well it's an
Italian movie with with a certain set of
characteristics it's not just any you
know it's not just any mystery film
which in Italy it is now there they make
a distinction between a jello is
technically a murder mystery but it's
like god of a lot of other elements now
it's not like a police procedural they
have a different word for that and I
think it's politte CEO test she or
something like that but that's a
different job that's more like where the
cop is the protector Thierry er death
wish or something like that that's a
different kind of movie that's not the
same thing well people giallo that
people might know well most of the
jealous people know are probably the
most famous one Zardari or John Timm oh
yeah you know Berg with a crystal
plumage deep red Tenebrae stuff like
that that you know very very famous
never seen but oh yeah that's because
you're a Philistine yeah
who doesn't know [ __ ] about horror well
it's a truth that I really don't like
Italian movies I know but see I know but
but a couple of those spaghetti westerns
I like yeah yeah I like good bad the
ugly
that's question it though yeah that's
question well they definitely have a
different aesthetic yeah okay so
basically the first there were like a
few um you know proto jello type films
and they were also actually influenced
there's a German there's a similar
German genre called Cryme which are kind
of like the same kind of thing like
crime thriller mystery thriller type of
thing but the first generally the first
giallo movie is the girl who knew too
much
Mario Bava and that was from 1963 now a
lot of the early jello films were
strongly influenced by Alfred Hitchcock
particularly psycho but the weird thing
is a lot of Hitchcock's later films were
actually influenced back they you know
buy jello huh so they kind of like
influenced each other in a way okay now
so why should an American horror movie
fan be interested in javanese well
here's the thing okay
jello movies like I said they have a
very particular aesthetic it's not just
a murder mystery is not just a crime
thriller it also has like all these
other really cool like elements to it
now because it's Italian it tends to
have a lot of like really exaggerated
like opera right and it also you know
it's like if you've lured colors and
like everyone is like you know all the
murders are super gory and like all that
kind of stuff back in the day we used to
call it we used to call this Bologna
very sperm Oni you're asking yeah yeah
it's got every flavor yeah it's like
Neapolitan four times over yeah yeah
I mean now is there I mean Italians
would do that back in the day yes but
mix all kinds of stuff together but they
yeah okay so like I said a jello
it'll-it'll usually have elements of
opera it'll usually usually have
elements like a like a real Grand
Guignol
I feel like super hyper violent also a
lot of elements of gothic horror some
more than others
traditional jello what ended up
happening Mario Bava he made girl who
knew too much like I said influenced by
Alfred Hitchcock that was in black and
white that one it did okay but it didn't
really make much cultural impact then he
made another one called blood and black
lace now this one was you know super
saturated color there was all these
murders happening you know at a at a
model what was it a fashion house yeah
so it was all bottles and stuff like
that and it didn't do that great but
honestly that movie was probably the
template for all of the movies that came
later but what ended up happening was
that Dario Argento in 1970 he made the
bird with the crystal plumage and that
had a huge cultural limp it was a huge
hit and then all these are so so it
wasn't the first jello but it was
actually the one that kind of kicked off
the whole giallo heyday which lasted
about ten years they're still making
them now like but the ones now I haven't
seen them but you know I've heard that
they're kind of just pastiches and
they're not exactly like the old ones we
just saw one in the theater that you
said was look like a jello when when
weight we saw a movie oh yeah you and I
went and saw it in theatres [ __ ]
remember that was kind of like a hot at
Houseman Oh crimson peak yeah no that
was a gothic horror but the lighting was
very Argento is okay I guess is probably
what I meant by that okay but here's
okay now the bird with the crystal
plumage was it kind of established a lot
of the tropes I mean blood and black
lace did too but here generally this is
what happens in a jello film the
protagonist of the film is usually
they're usually not from wherever the
the film is set so if the film is set in
Italy which bird with the crystal
plumage is then the protagonist is
actually American so it's usually a
tourist or they're there for
so it's like an outsider and then while
they're there they witness a murder it
has nothing to do with them they just
happen to be walking past and they just
unluckily they see a murder right and
then there's usually and Dario Argento
did this a lot there's usually some
aspect of the murder scene that either
they can't remember correctly or there's
something wrong with it and they can't
put their finger on it or something like
that so they spend a lot of the movie
like kind of going over going what what
was the matter with that why did I you
know because that's like kind of the key
to solving the whole mystery and in a
lot of G olives not not always but this
is a pretty underlying current that the
cops are usually skeptical of the
witness they either think they did it or
they think they were imagining things
or you know something like that and then
the cops are usually like not that
effective right in some cases yeah
they're idiots usually the person that
witnessed the murder is kind of put into
the position of trying to figure out who
the killer was before they get killed
good so there's a that's that's kind of
the classic plot that's not you know
they're not all like that but I'm kind
of I tend to think I'm like a jello
purist I'm like it's not a murder
mystery I feel like it's not a jello
right you know what I mean
like because the whole point of the
jello is you're figuring out who the
killer is right and in classic mystery
thriller fashion you usually have all
these weird little clues you have all
these like shifty characters that are
like red herrings that could be the
killer right and [ __ ] like that sure all
have motive we saw we saw an Italian
movie not long ago on was it YouTube
remember that which was that a Jala
which one - which one are you talking
about it was the one that had Brooke
Shields in it oh um that was not that
was not an Italian movie it wasn't no I
thought it was it just had Italian
Americans in it yeah that's right head
dude the Catholic Chur that was kind
yeah yeah yeah it was Alice sweet Alice
Alice sweet Alice
has some jello elements I have seen that
called the jello okay I guess it could
be under a super loose definition I
don't know see okay there's a lot of
there's a lot of back and forth about
what is it jello and what's not like
what's that movie felt like an Italian
movie watching it we didn't have a very
Italian aesthetic and everybody in it
was italian-american and they were there
was Catholic Church all time there's
murders happen and yeah thought was the
little girl doing it but it turned out
it was yeah it did have it didn't have a
lot of elements that it also had a lot
of elements of don't look now not guys
that's a classic a classic Donald
Sutherland upset in Venice just know
just so you guys know I hate fiction
almost I basically hate fiction I don't
like movies either very later they very
yeah I like some movies like very few
thank you and the ones I like everybody
else seems to hate not well-known I like
Prometheus yeah nobody liked it yes some
people like some people like that like
horror movies and stuff like that they
don't they don't really draw me in not
scared they don't think they're scary
well a lot of them I don't think it's
scary I just like I'm interested in like
that's like the same thing you know I
think they're real Sammy although I like
the old 70 stuff well yeah well that's
what these are yeah these were all 70 if
you haven't even like those back then
yeah yeah I just don't like there's
something about the way about the way
way Italians edit things and maybe it
was the dubbing and a sound it was I
would rather prefer and honestly they
did double out of them into English
beginner well because what they would do
in all Italian movies they kind of did
this they would usually have actors from
lots of different countries you know
they have Germans in a British they have
Americans in our country this was
happening well no not necessarily but
what they would do is they would have
everybody to speak in their native
language and then they would just dub
jump right into the same language I
remember I'm just looking and feeling
like really extremely b-movie that's how
I read well some of them were but some
of them were it was just kind of like
any other genre there were were there
was like a handful of examples that were
really good and there were big budget
and then they were like dozens and
dozens of like cheap knock-offs
we were watching that American movie the
what was the one that the guy that did
escape from New York and the thing
what's his name John Carpenter John
Coffey we were watching that John
Carpenter flick remember that about
pensive dark prince of darkness and then
the way that that killer killed that
person was a pair of scissors or a knife
I remember you said that's right out of
a jello movie yeah and actually yeah and
I was actually gonna talk about that
later but I guess it doesn't really
matter I can talk about it right now but
um even though this is like not even in
order but whatever I was gonna say that
the giallo movie is was a huge huge
influence on American slasher flicks
huge and actually a lot of your you know
directors John Carpenter and even like
the newer guys that like Eli Roth it
doesn't torture porn and stuff like that
our super super into gel movies and you
can actually see it like I said we were
watching Prince of Darkness John
Carpenter um not a great movie got a
stay and I love John Carpenter John
Carpenter's hitting me he's very
hit-or-miss and that one was really a
mess for my day he really did not like
Prince of Darkness but there is one
scene in it where that woman comes out
across the courtyard to stab that guy
with the scissors of the knife or
whatever and she's kind of floating yeah
I was like man that is so Argento yeah
he was on a skateboard yeah that was an
Argento [ __ ] homage right there had
to have been yeah I like it I'll tell
you that one when carpenters on he's
spot-on
I love the skate from New York did you
guys haven't seen escape from New York
see that one and the John Carpenter's
The Thing the original one well yeah
that's the man that scared me so bad
yeah and I was a kid when they came out
yeah that's still an awesome movie and
the acting is really good in those yeah
yeah okay we were talking about like
characteristics of a jello okay so it's
not just a murder mystery there are also
other stylistic elements generally the
killer is not revealed to the end the
killer is usually someone that's in this
pool of
you know suspects but it's usually the
least person you expect most of the time
they fool me which is good
it's never the most obvious person the
killer
usually is masked or they are you know
they're wearing like a black trench coat
black hat black gloves yeah disguise
yeah they're usually wearing a disguise
never they never ever ever use guns
always knives straight razors
sometimes ropes but it's usually bladed
instruments because it's kind of a I
don't know it's like a phallic type of
thing plus it's bloodier yeah Bloods
always orange well it's like bright red
it's like like temper paint yeah cuz
like I said everything has to be super
super exaggerated right not always
they're not all like that some of them
are kind of gritty or more realistic
specially lucci Oh full cheese ones
which I kind of want to talk about one
of his later cuz all right it's it's one
that doesn't get a lot of love I guess
usually the victims are scantily clad
women usually the characters are usually
kind of jet-set real modern hip kind of
people used photographers models artists
you know they're not usually poor people
or just regular people are usually suit
glamorous they're usually really
glamorous and a lot of the sets and
stuff like that they're either like old
gothic kind of looking [ __ ] or they're
like ultra modern hip apartments type
stuff and a lot of the fashions are like
super up-to-date for you know for
whenever they were made sixties or
seventies so they're you know they're
really like hip looking people with all
these really cool ensembles and stuff
also there's usually and this is kind of
mentioned a lot usually the score of it
the music of it is actually pretty
distinctive and I think Dario Argento
probably is the best known for this with
his work with the band goblin he used a
lot of prog rock like really loud prog
rock and now Alan Parsons Project kind
of but yeah it actually you wouldn't
think it works it actually does it's
really cool and actually I have I have a
couple of Goblin CDs that have like all
their work because they didn't just work
with him they worked with a bunch of
other directors as well but but a lot of
their [ __ ] is really awesome like
facilities but especially their score
for Suspiria that's like it that's
[ __ ] awesome I love it even those
berries not a gel and I'll fight you but
um I'll talk about that later
but uh you know they'll also use like
free jazz stuff like that and here's the
thing a lot of contentions you know
there's a lot of contentions made about
what's a giallo what's not a jail
there's this really good blog it's
actually really nicely designed blog too
called the jello files and he makes the
argument that
a lot of jell-o movies that are
considered jell-o movies are not jealous
like he says Sergio Martinez all the
colors of the dark is not a jello moment
he's saying he you see the guy who runs
a blog yeah what's his name ya know I
don't know I just I just yeah I just
kind of discovered this okay but so yeah
okay but he's good yeah all right I like
this blog actually but um and I don't
know okay I don't know how I feel
he also says that the house with the
Laughing windows which is considered a
classic jello is not a jail now I can
see why he says that I wrote a blog post
myself about both of those movies all
the colors of the dark and House of the
Laughing windows and they do have some
elements of jell-o but they're not I
don't it's not a classic jello okay and
there's another one and I can talk about
this because I just saw this one the
other day
this one actually turns up on a lot of
lists but I would not call this one a
jello at all and that is the perfume of
the lady in black other than the title
oh and that's another thing I could talk
talk because jello title is the [ __ ]
best I love them perfume of the lady in
black and it's usually considered a
giallo
but I don't think it's a jello because
one nobody really gets killed until the
end it's not like the classic jello you
know series of murders and you're trying
to figure out like with the clues and
stuff and you're trying to figure out
who the murderer is really knowing dies
until the end and there's no gore until
the end also it's not it's it's more
like the protagonist is it's more like a
Polanski film
honestly like repulsion or like
Rosemary's Baby or the tenant even
though the tenant came later I think
that weird movies yeah but it was kind
of like that in the sense that the
protagonist was this woman you weren't
sure if she was just going batshit or if
there was this weird like conspiracy
like to drive her crazy or to get her to
kill herself for who knows and you know
a lot of the a lot of the imagery was
real dreamlike and you weren't really
you know was really ambiguous and don't
get me wrong I loved that but I don't
think it was a gel okay I don't think
you're just a regular horror movie it
was like a psychological horror movie
but you know people who could argue and
me if they want to honestly I think a
lot of people call Suspiria a jello and
I think they're just doing that cuz
Dario Argento made it cuz yeah Dario
Argento made a [ __ ] ton of jealous and
he's probably the best known I say
jell-o's it should be jolly sorry but um
he made a [ __ ] ton of them Suspiria not
really a gel yeah and here's the thing I
don't think it's a jello because it's
supernatural
it's a supernatural horror movie now I'm
not saying that some some jolly didn't
have you know supernatural elements cuz
he even spent ok deep red or profound or
also if you prefer had kind of a
supernatural element cuz the woman at
the beginning was a psychic and she was
a real psychic like she could read
people's thoughts and [ __ ] like that but
I think there's a point where okay I can
swing with psychic and it was still a
jello in the classic sense where there
was a string of murders and the guy had
to figure out like what the what the
[ __ ] was that he saw to figure out who
the murderer was
but Suspiria yes there's a series of
murders that are hyper violent and weird
and operatic and stuff like that yes
there's a prog-rock score yes there is
this crazy you know supersaturated
exaggerated lighting and stuff like that
but dude it's witches it's not good I
mean it's witches in a ballet school
it's like a coven okay so it's like it's
not I don't know and see that's the
thing and and the person that writes the
giallo files they also say that all the
colors of the dark is not a jello which
I guess I can see because it kind of has
the same thing as the perfume of the
lady in black it's kind of like there's
a satanic or black magic type of cult
and they're following this woman around
and you don't know if what she's seeing
is real like there's a guy walking
around killing people and she you don't
know if it's a real person or if it's
just because she kept seeing in her
dreams and she liked that so if you want
to call it if you want to call this
jellified I called him jello on my blog
when I wrote about him and I'm not gonna
get all butthurt about it but Suspiria
no Joe no and neither is Inferno oh and
no she's talking about I see I've never
seen any of these moves you haven't see
that's a me that's what you assumed
though because like a lot mentioned a
lot of people watch these well yeah okay
well that's well I wouldn't talk about
it from their behavior when I was
talking about [ __ ] do you think I am
bounces back just having fun you know
for a long time but I knew he would be
like I knew you because I said I know
that you're not gonna know anything that
I'm talking about and you're just gonna
make fun if we go that's good that's
good because you're assuming that no one
else you guys are horror fans you know
[ __ ] Dario Argento is it list Jesus
Christ I first I heard you don't know
anything
oh [ __ ] okay okay so here's the halfway
point and after the break we'll come
back and all just Yap on and on more
about cuz I just and I love this topic
tell them more about it okay well I'll
walk you through it alright we'll be
back in just a few minutes their project
Entertainment Network presents Buttercup
of doom with your host Kelly Owen just a
girl a girl who writes horror and
thriller fiction talks to bugs jumps and
puddles and now hosts a weekly podcast
full of opinions advice and a touch of
gypsy wisdom whether it's current
affairs or social media nightmares join
me as I rant and rave and offer up a big
old bucket a common sense Wednesday's on
Buttercup of doom subculture corsets and
clothing is our favorite store for
unusual clothing shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices
soap culture also offers the cool
selection of shoes and accessories
steampunk gothic apparel retro corsets
and so much more at subculture corsets
and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that's
subculture corsets calm make sure you
use the discount code 13 o'clock for a
10% discount subculture corsets
or visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back talking about giallo
movies which time is it oh [ __ ] about
not lost no I'm over here dog paddlers
I'm just trying to figure out I'm dog
paddle and then to see if I don't know
that's a very nice analogy like yeah
yeah alright so uh let's say what where
did I where did I leave off oh I don't
know you're talking about your favorite
Channel movies why some were pajama
movies and why some weren't yeah here's
the thing there's because there's so
much overlap with other genres you know
with the gothic horror genre films are
even kind of you know later slasher
movies who is the most underappreciated
giallo a writer or director I see okay
that was a good question well yeah I
don't even know subject I don't know
about underrated director cuz I think
all of them were pretty um you know
we're pretty well-liked at the time like
I said some of them were better than
others you know like I saw some the
other day like seven blood-stained
orchids and you know a Cutler know the
blood-stained shadows sorry about that
that I saw the other day classic jello
not great but you know if you're kind of
into that kind of thing then you know
you'll dig it but it wasn't like wow
that was amazing
you know I mean not like say you know
deep red or anything like that which is
kind of considered one of the one of the
best ones but the what my wanted set
what what made Italy different you know
I mean yeah what made them make java
movies what didn't have access to TV
were they making a lot of ease or what
was the deal yeah they were but here's
the thing like like I said there are um
counterparts like in other countries
like I said Germany had the Cryme films
right and you know we kind of had
slasher horror you know it's a psycho
peeping tom oh that was British but um
you know that kind of [ __ ] but for some
reason the Italians are super fun I
guess maybe it was because of their
opera tradition they are super into like
sex and violence okay so they said we'll
take a mystery like our crime thriller
and we'll just put tits and blood okay
up to 11
you know what I mean and that you know
they did the same thing like with their
zombie movies it's just like well let's
have Somme B's but with more more
decapitation right more Adel and pale
man write more songs pink Oh more of
that they're just for some reason
they're super super into that [ __ ] and
they really love to show I mean there's
a great there's a great [ __ ] seen in
Suspiria again down the giallo but
there's a great [ __ ] seeing this
period he stabs for me to the heart and
there's a heart it's just like right
there just like open when I was in here
and they just show a knife just like
plunging into it when I was a kid you
know was growing up in California
Southern California and of course we had
a lot people from Mexico living in the
area and there at the little corner
stores we find like Mexican magazines
how about movies
yeah and they had some bizarre [ __ ]
going on in there - yeah you know like
Mexican bandits sicken fighting roosters
on guys and they had blades on the
roosters and was cutting their heads off
and you know the Mexicans were into that
too they had the MEK Mexican wrestler
yeah he's there you know like sample
math man yeah they had they had like
photographs of it in the magazines
wrestlers fight each other blood
everywhere I kind of love that well it's
kind of like a crush on or between I
mean I know people think it's weird like
the luchador type of stuff like yeah you
know where they put them in like you
know Samson versus the vampire women and
all that kind of stuff it's like why
don't you put a Mexican restaurant like
fighting vampires stuff like that but
it's basically their version of a
superhero yeah I mean my buddies you're
like in a third grade we find those
magazines on the newsstand they're in
Carson California
be traumatized cut his head off with a
rooster that's gonna be the quote for
this episode they cut his head off with
a roof steak cut his head off in the
restaurant yeah it was a woman in the
mix - yeah yeah and I don't think was a
photograph it was a cartoon yeah that
was a like a billboard as you know it's
a drawing for like a movie poster yeah
you'd have the job of movie posters ago
it was like that but it showed like a
guy sick and a rooster off to another
guy and the blades on the back of the
rooster was cutting the other guy's face
off and then there's
a half-naked woman in the mix to someone
okay we gotta find that yeah that's the
rats ever heard how that dude that had
to do that the dude that threw the
rooster you know I had a head of
sombrero and uh in a poncho and you know
an ammo belt or his shoulder and
lever-action carbines like Cowboys
they're like Gauchos yeah Mexican
Cowboys okay yeah well it's actually
funny you brought that up because really
the only other the only other country
besides Italy where giallo was like at a
huge date heyday was Spain and there
were also a couple of good examples that
came out as Bantu but you know Italy
mostly and it was really only a ten year
time period kind of his from 1968 to
about 1978 was kind of that heyday they
were coming out like all the time yeah
like there was like almost 70 movies
like in here in the same genre and like
I said not women fantastic if you like
the genre you know you can you can see
most of them on YouTube yeah now like I
said there were a few made later but um
Ashley OH for my money okay juice you
asked me before about underrated
directors and stuff like that like I
said I don't know about underrated
directors but one of my favorite giallo
movies and this one also had a bit of a
supernatural element was by Lucci of
full G which like I said Lucci of full G
most people in the US I mean they I know
they he they know he directed jelly but
he's most famous for his like super
boring zombie films you know zombie the
beyond house for the cemetery stuff like
that but he also he made some jolly - he
made a don't torture duckling he made
New York Ripper you know he made one on
top of the other which I guess some
people consider JLo even though it's
kind of more in erotic whatever I don't
know what it was but um the chick from
danger Diaboli in it but one of my
favorite jello movies was actually made
by him and it's called well over here
it's called the psychic it's actually
probably none better seven notes in
black and it had a that had a
supernatural now this one was not like
it wasn't like super lurid it wasn't but
it did have a lot of giallo elements in
this sense that and it has this [ __ ]
thematic element and I and I don't know
if any of you guys know if there's a
name for it I don't know if there's a
name for it or not but what ends up
happening is the woman who's the psychic
is
main character and at the beginning she
has a vision where she sees like this
sort of disjointed series of scenes and
the the cool thing about the movie is
that the way as the movie goes on and
like each of these scenes like starts
happening in real in reality right and
it's so it's almost like you kind of
know what's gonna happen but then you
kind of don't like because it kind of
subverts like oh I thought you know I
thought the version of the division of
this person being dead was gonna mean
this and it said you know what I mean
and it's and her vision is kind of a
mixture of like past present and future
so you don't know what already happened
and what's gonna happen and it's just
it's a really really good movie and it's
like I said it's not super it's not
super gross like most of his other most
of his out movies and stuff like that I
think probably the grossest thing and it
is like a head wound and it's really
you've never seen and you've never even
seen like any of the real like nasty
like like cannibal ferox and all that
kind of [ __ ] which does it actually is
it cannibal ferox or or eaten alive or
couple the other ones and actually those
are still banned in a lot of countries
because mostly because it had real
animal cruelty you know like they really
killed animals in it right stuff like
that and actually he gotta move I think
it was amber to Lindsay that directed
will he directed cannibal ferox but he
was it him
I can't member who it was him or the
other guy that got in trouble he
actually got brought to court because he
thought they thought he made a snuff
film if there was not there was a zombie
movie from I think is from the early
eighties maybe the late 70s that I've
been wanting to see only thing I ever
saw was that was the poster for it was
just called zombie
yeah that's Lucio Fulci okay yeah and it
has a rotten head with the rotten head
with the worm yeah were yeah I got that
t-shirt yeah that says we're going to
eat you on it was it was it movie good
yeah it's awesome
I gotta see it it's like it's very
Italian you know but it's like it's
super boring yeah I see them I might add
I probably out on DVD and then actually
it's nowhere cuz I have a lot of Felicio
bulgy movies you know yeah you brought I
don't know I don't know if you'd like it
or not I
I'd seen it for a long time to be honest
anything like shockwaves I like the moon
I like that was a good time the Nazi
Zombies Nazi Zombies yeah well now is I
can't remember I think it was uh it
might have been zombie wo full tree
movie yeah was it Dom be that had a
zombie fighting a shark underwater oh I
gotta see it I'm pretty sure it was that
was the same is it the famous scene yeah
famous scene that um cheesy not really
by the show because they can't afford to
like build a shark like in Jaws it
wasn't a mechanical sharks today is he
is he is he swimming is he floating or
is he standing on I think he's standing
on the boss the shark yeah oh yeah how
big is the shark well it's not like jaws
a bike a bike with your hair like five
six for sure
surprise it's a diver messing around
with a real shark yeah my bayonets like
I said I would say that for a long time
yeah now I've heard that oh I was gonna
say that interestingly but even though
jello were largely influenced like I
said by American and British crime
fiction and also by Alfred Hitchcock
but then ironically after the after the
giallo heyday had passed in the late 70s
they kind of became the springboard for
the American slasher film now an
American slasher film is essentially a
jello without the mystery element which
as I said makes it not just getting down
yeah they're just basically like boobs
blood you know slashing at the end it
doesn't have I mean the hold the whole
point of a jello I think is that you
have the reveal of the killer at the end
like a mystery and what do you think the
first American slasher film is I know
the first one I remember it was just you
know Friday the 13th but I know that
that wasn't the first one that was the
first one I remember
no um first when I saw that's the thing
I people probably consider psycho the
first I mean that was the like a pruno
slasher
I'm a full-fledged slasher a
full-fledged slasher that's a that's a
good question I'd have to look but um
did Halloween predate Halloween was in
1978 so that's before yeah Friday the
13th yeah
now what was Texas Chainsaw Massacre man
that was 74 so that we were going what's
that a slasher though I don't know if
I'd call that a slasher I think it
probably was yeah that's another thing
see I don't know it you kind of like you
know it when you see it right but I
guess you could call Texas Chainsaw
Massacre a slasher how they didn't show
that much in it though I mean I the cool
thing about Texas Chainsaw Massacre is
that they didn't show a lot but they
made you think you saw which is kind of
a genius thing right it's hard to it's
hard to pull off okay but it yeah
actually since you brought up Friday the
13th and I was talking about the the
influence of the jello in the slasher
film if Friday the 13th part to you guys
if you remember the iconic scene in
there we're like the two where the
couple is [ __ ] and Jason comes in and
stabs that both of them through the day
or the sphere okay that scene was
straight-up ripped off from a G olivella
bro twitch of the death nerve probably
better known as baya blood over here
Mario Baba's hyper hyper violent yellow
film ice actually I saw it recently I've
been wanting to see it for a long time
and and I finally got around to seeing
it and that film was batshit yeah I just
I couldn't believe how bad [ __ ] it was
Fred Friday the 13th part two is pretty
good I like I was the best one I think
out of the genre and I remember seeing
that thing you know I get over at my
cousin's house in Mississippi spend the
night over there hit a big old house and
we stay up late at night much like you
know MTV or an on TV what numbers of
calls HBO yeah we watch HBO and Cinemax
and that come on I spend the rest of the
night scared walking around you know
afraid I would see Jason around every
corner well yeah those were pretty scary
we're back in the day the country the
the thing that I think the thing that
distinguishes a slasher film from a
jello there's not a lot of distinctions
okay but like I said a jello has the
killer reveal identity at the end a
slasher you pretty much know who the
killer is right like Halloween it's
Michael
yeah you know Jason it's Jason port well
let's say the first one is not but you
know miss y'all you are alert you don't
know until the end yes so it's more so
it's more like a traditional like Agatha
Christie whodunit type of thing except
with like super violence and gothic
elements and you know like I said some
of them more than others like you know
if you want to say one that's kind of
more in the Gothic genre the knight
Evelyn came out of the grave which I
always like to say spoiler alert and
that was another thing I wanted to
mention they all have the best [ __ ]
titles I love giallo titles and okay
whoever out there in internet land made
the Do It Yourself jello website where
you can just go and it gives you a title
and a director name and a plot out it
just generates it and it just generates
them there they are delightful yeah do
one and actually well the one that's up
right now is a gecko that stands in the
center of the ever-widening pool of red
directed by Fulvio Lucci ahaha yeah I
don't know okay let's see what does this
one say moonlit shadows on a frozen
landscape directed by Franco Franco six
dead orchids in a frozen landscape okay
see there you traces of dark red on a
blue satin pillow actually I kind of
like that one there - only bear - yeah
well because there's Umberto Lenzi was
one of the was one of the directors that
was kind of well known but um yeah so I
did so I did talk about the psychic I
like that but yeah gothic armed elements
[ __ ] like that also I kind of wanted to
talk a little bit too about I like
here's one thing one thing I always
really liked about jell-o moves and they
don't always do this but I like the
trope and Dario Argento did this a lot
as I mentioned where the person that
witnesses the crime that kicks off the
whole movie there's always like some
little detail that's bugging them and
like they spend the whole movie like you
know spoiler alerts you guys but I'm
sure most of most of horror fans have
seen like deep red and I've seen bird
with the crystal plumage because they're
kind of classics of the genre but you
know say bird with the crystal plumage
beginning in the movie the American guys
walking past an art gallery and it has
big glass big last front and it's at
night and he sees two people struggling
like a woman and a man and it's a man in
a black hat and a black trenchcoat
struggling with a woman and then she
gets stabbed he tried he runs in and
tries to help her but then the killer
pushes a button and closes the glass
doors and the other side so he's trapped
between these two glass windows and he's
like just watching her and she does get
saved eventually but he keeps replaying
the scene in his head going man
something was the matter with that scene
what was it I can't figure it out and
he's like I just feel like if I could
figure it out then I would know who the
killer was
and the detail that he can't that he
couldn't play so they couldn't figure
out spoiler alert
was that when the two people were
struggling the woman had the knife in
her hand instead of the man's you think
the whole thing you think the man is the
killer right but really it was her she
was trying to stab the guy okay and the
same thing happened in deep-red the
British writer who he sees the psychic
woman being killed up in her apartment
window and the thing that's bugging him
is that he's like when I looked up in
the window he's like I thought I saw a
painting like behind her and then when
he went up to the apartment with the
police he's like it wasn't there so he's
like what who took it and why did they
take it so it's for the whole thing it
was bothering him and then it turns out
at the end that it actually wasn't a
painting that he had seen and it was a
mirror and he had actually seen the
killer's face in the mirror and he just
so he didn't you know when he went in
there and saw the painting he's like I
didn't see a painting that looked like
what I saw it's because he's the
killer's face with the mirror and you
know same thing kind of happened and
another thing too and I forgot to
mention this but that another aspect of
jail this is also really common and this
probably this trope probably came from
psycho and from Alfred Hitchcock I would
imagine but whoever the killer is they
usually have some kind of madness or
mental illness that is spurred by a
childhood trauma
you know usually sexual in nature or
they or they with
their parents killing each other or
something like that like in like in deep
red the the protagonist you know saw
their saw their mother kill their father
yeah and you know [ __ ] like that and
sometimes they'll show like flashbacks
of that kind of thing but there's
there's usually like a real psycho
sexual element to you know to the
killer's motivation if they have any
sometimes it's just something simple
like blackmail I tend not to like those
as much because the thing that I like
about giallo is its over-the-top yeah
you know kind of operatic elements so
the ones that are kind of more low-key
that are just kind of like oh well this
person was blackmailing all these people
you know they're still alright but it's
not quite as fun right that's why I feel
like Dario Argento's are a lot a lot
more fun than ones like you know ones
like um the Seven blood-stained orchids
where I'm pretty sure it was just
blackmail that linked all the victims
and then actually that was another one
where the cops were like total idiots
because the the woman what happens in
that one is that the woman she's there's
been two murders already and then the
main woman her name is Julia and she
gets attacked by the killer
but then the killer is frightened off
but the killer thinks she's dead but
she's not and so the police like staged
a mock funeral for her like so the
killer thinks she's dead so they can
draw him out but then there could the
cops are kind of useless and then her
and her boyfriend figure out what the
connection is between all these
seemingly unrelated victims and they
give the police a list of hey these
women are going to get killed and then
the police like just with it so you know
like it does really seem like gee allas
you know unlike you know the more police
procedural type theme gelas are much
more like [ __ ] the police right or
they're much more anti-authority because
there's like they're useless and the
witness you usually have to figure
everything out because the police can't
catch cold
I guess well if the police were any good
that movie couldn't happen well exactly
that truth exactly
so that's kind of what happens with that
Oh what oh we're almost to the end you
should already call me yeah but um yeah
well you know this it kinda got some
[ __ ] and then like an hour from now I'll
be like dad damn it I forgot to say this
and that cuz I you know like I said I
have all and and I get excited because I
have because I've seen so many of these
if you guys want to go to my blog it's
goddess of Hellfire calm and I've
actually written about a lot of kind of
the lesser-known jell-o's I read about
knight Evelyn came out of the grave and
I wrote about all the colors of the dark
and House of laughing windows and a
bunch of a blood-stained shadow a bunch
of and I wrote about perfume the lady in
black to him though I don't think that's
jela so if you want to go and read those
some of them are kind of funny so if you
want to if you want to read the
breakdowns of them but other than that
oh and also I wanted to remind everyone
again that my new book is out yeah
unseen hand if you're into poltergeist
stuff it's pretty much like hundreds of
hundred and something cases of
poltergeist activity it's gonna be it's
gonna be a benchmark book in that
subject it's kind of do old school books
yeah I kind of like it old like you know
from the seventies when you have this
pair of psychologists like William roll
and stuff and they were kind of writing
those compilations of their case writing
so if it's kind of like that all that
stuff yeah so love those
yeah I did too that's why I wanted to
write one like that yeah I like him
because they were creepy they were kind
of dry and that dry and that's kind of
made it creepy because you're just this
is not see the police reported this and
that this and that is no it's not like
you're watching one of those lame new
episodes of the haunting you know where
there's like making everything yeah
making everything episode like it's when
that's not that would happen although
that sells those books those guys are
just making [ __ ] but to me that's not a
boy they got like over a thousand rupees
maybe that's not as scary and and
honestly the same thing applies
generally to horror fiction it's why
other than jealous like I said I'm like
jealous because they're over-the-top but
I don't think they're scary the only
horror movies that I find scary are
movies that are real
subtle yeah like like a subtle
psychological tip that don't show much
but they just make like I said if
something's gonna scare me it's gonna be
like the [ __ ] David Lynch movie or
something like that it's not gonna be
like something with like goes pop the
only thing the only thing recently that
scares me are things that are like super
plausible like what was that series of
or they're like hour-long too and I
think with masters Apollo masters well
that was from like 10 or 15 years ago
was it okay well they had that episode
where those aliens spray the screw fly
solution to fly so they sprayed
something on on the planet Earth and it
caused all of the men to kill all the
women yeah that's right that's like it's
freaked me out I know I remember you
baby oh man I like that one but that
wasn't my favorite my favorite one of my
favorite one of those and I actually
wrote about that I've read about these
on my blog too but my favorite episode
of that well imprint was actually my
favorite one but my second favorite one
was cigarette burns the one with Norman
Reedus
because that because I loved the idea of
a movie that would drive people crazy if
they saw it I love that oh yeah I
remember yeah and they have and there
was that great [ __ ] scene we're like
ooh don't care dude put like pulls out
his intestines and the threads in here
the projector yeah I was [ __ ] awesome
yeah I love that shows I love that [ __ ]
but like I said it's funny because we
were just talking about this the other
day I said if a movie if a horror movie
like I love horror movies of all kinds
but if a horror movies gonna scare me
ones that are ones that are not
plausible scare me more that like ones
at about serial killers and [ __ ] like
that you know look these like Rob Zombie
movies or whatever they don't scare me
as much as either ghost stories are like
psychological kind of horror like I said
one of the creepiest movies like the
tenant right that Roman Polanski's
that's freaked the [ __ ] out of me that
is a freaky ass man I haven't seen that
in a long time I don't know because
because ambiguity is much scarier to me
like a serial killer I'm like it's a
dude he's a serial killer big deal it's
like you can put a finger on it he's a
lot of Roman Polanski samples
and what a minute Skinny Puppy sauce
yeah they don't I mean even though rosin
down with that even though Roman
Polanski goes my head what do I see even
though Roman Polanski's a horse is kind
of a horrible person i intestines I see
me in - well you just did it
even though Roman Polanski is a horrible
person he made some [ __ ] awesome
movies and I love the tenant it's
actually one of my favorite movies okay
so we're going to wrap it up for this
week about Gela movies and even though
I'm not gonna make Tom watch any because
he probably won't like them and then
because he likes to hate on stuff no I
don't own that what we're just not too
much into Italian I would like to see
the zombie movie okay
well I'll show you I don't know if you
like it or not you might yeah you might
dig it I haven't seen it a long time so
I don't know I liked I liked all of his
lychee offal cheese zombie movies
actually he made movies in pretty much
every genre and even made like comedies
he made like sex comedies made cop buddy
movies he made all kind of [ __ ] but he's
been and he made some jealous who lizard
in a woman's skin and I think I
mentioned a couple other ones but um
he's probably best known for the zombie
movies but I'm sure the beyond does his
best one and I and I don't think
anyone's gonna fight me on that cuz it
beyond is probably his best movie that's
like his magnum opus okay and that's
kind of a zombie movie I guess there's
kind of zombies in it but not really but
uh okay so another shout out to project
Entertainment Network and our Monroes
Amelia go to the project Entertainment
Network patreon at patreon.com slash
project and net and give them a buck or
two and supports our podcasts and
supports lots of other podcast they also
have a store with shirts and buttons and
all kinds of stuff you can buy and we
have a store also at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock where you can buy some t-shirts
and there's five different designs on
there at all moments all very cool so go
buy some and you know come on love us
and that'll do it for this week's
episode bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]